how many people by show of hands don't
know a lot about me or my spiel I'm just
trying to context the crowd all right
I'm gonna go very very quick because
that's a lower number than normal and I
don't wanna spend too much time on
something a lot of people know but I
think I'll matter and then I kind of
want to navigate and very honestly spoke
with the organizers beforehand I
actually want to save even within my
time slot even though I know we have a
panel coming up I'd like to do about 20
minutes of Q&A as well because the truth
is you know if you ask me how I think
about the world I think about it in very
simple terms why in the world would you
possibly want to buy what I'm selling
right I have a very difficult time right
now with what we're living through
because we're living through the great
audacity of entrepreneurs and the great
growth of fake entrepreneurs we're
living in a time right now because the
Internet is so incredible where
everybody thinks they're entitled to
start a business and it should be
successful because we're getting caught
up in the hyperbole of things like
Instagram and other things of that
nature and we're not looking at the raw
data that 99% of these startups are
losing millions of dollars in 24 months
and then they just say they write a blog
post saying sorry I gave it a good shot
and everybody thinks they're a hero and
I think that's great because I'm a pure
entrepreneur and I do think everybody if
they have it in them should be an
entrepreneur but I also think the same
thing about being a great football
player or an actress or a soccer player
I do think this is more of a talent
which gets me back to what I said to
start this sentence we are not speaking
enough about value right we're not
speaking up about value when I come and
speak when i schlepped over here in a
flight when I'm asked and feel very
flattered to come and speak here the
entire time I'm on the plane the entire
time my hotel room I'm like well why are
the 70% of the people in this audience
who've heard my talks many times before
or seen my youtube videos or heard my
one-liners why are they going to be
entertained why are they gonna be
interested why is it worthwhile
what value might bring it to 30 40
percent of people that just raised their
hands couple things I'm [ __ ] pissed at
you for not knowing who I am and number
two I feel very confident that I'm gonna
be able to deliver quality for you
because you haven't heard some of this
spiel before and I tend to do good in
that realm but what I spend a lot of
time on is what everybody in this room
should spend all their time on and that
is what value my providing why should I
be chosen to do work for somebody if I'm
doing consulting or b2b why should
somebody buy my stuff why should
somebody read my book over and over my
life surrounds itself over one core
narrative which is if I don't bring more
value than what I'm asking in return
whether that's your attention which is
becoming more and more of the issue
actually I think the money part is
becoming easier I don't think it's the
money I don't think it's hard you know
luckily we live in a world where a lot
of people can't afford a $20.00 book or
can afford a definitely can afford a
free YouTube video to watch but that
time how many people familiar with uber
raise your hand if you're familiar with
uber the iPhone app very nice for the
ones that didn't raise their hand uber
is an app on demand it's actually now
making a lot of noise in in Europe I've
been paying attention I'm an investor in
uber blew up in the US over the last
three years it's on demand black car
taxi service you open up your app you
need a button the cars there it's
actually more expensive in most markets
than the normal transportation of a taxi
but it is completely on fire and
everybody is completely confused to why
everybody thinks that it's cool or the
uber is selling transportation I'm here
to tell you that uber sells time the one
thing that I know that every single
person here values after the health of
their family and friends and money is
time and that's what I spend all my time
thinking about catching a glimpse of the
last presentation and kind of following
the hashtag here today we can talk about
the things that I believe in loving your
community and giving back this and that
all of that is tremendous but the truth
is this thing that scares the [ __ ] out
of me is that you don't have time none
of you in this room have time and that
is becoming more
more of the asset that you cherish and
it is completely dictating my marketing
and how I sell and what I'm trying to do
for a living as a business person and
kind of the thematics
of all of where this is evolved if you
think back to everything we believe in
the people in here that have followed
social over the last decade half decade
we believe in do nice for the community
put out stuff that's value if it doesn't
give me goosebumps [ __ ] it all that
stuff right we believe in that why is
that important because it's hitting
ahead and this is something a lot of us
were not paying attention to and very
honestly something I wasn't paying a
whole lot attention to as as we were
talking about all these nice things it's
now not a nice to have it is now going
to be a must have because as this was
all happening over here over here
something much scarier was happening
which is we now live in a 24/7 365 world
do you you know there's a mixture here
there's some gray hairs in the crowd
I'm starting to get them too there's
some youngsters in the crowd for the
youngsters in the crowd this may not
make sense but for the people that are
35 and older like me do you remember
when the work day actually ended
remember remember one like you know like
I used to think I was a workaholic for
the people that don't know me I grew up
in my dad's liquor store business I once
went an eight-year period taking two
days off a year for eight straight years
and working by going to the liquor store
at seven o'clock in the morning and
coming home at 10:00 p.m. every [ __ ]
day that was my life I deemed myself a
workaholic right that guy that I was
from 1998 to 2005 is lazy
compared to who I am today not because I
got more energy or better because the
world shifted on me because now at like
when I wake up at 2:30 in the morning to
take a piss I grab my phone and tweet
back to somebody saying thanks bro
I mean we've gotten we have gotten into
a world where when you get an email at
11:50 p.m. at night people genuinely on
the other end things there's a fairly
good chance you may respond to them
within three or four minutes let me ask
you a very interesting question that's
tapping into this psychology if you're
not paying attention to it as much as I
am by show of hands and I don't want
your head nod
I've been slept in here for the last 14
hours so I want your full hand to this
question and don't lie cuz lying is the
devil how many people in this room and
you're not gonna want to raise your hand
if you're a proper citizen but I need
you to because I want you to show
everybody what's actually happening here
how many people in this room now
actually get upset when another human
being
calls them raise your hand raise it high
raise it high
front row area look back at what I'm
looking at here as a matter of fact do
me a huge favor can you just stand up
please I know you're gonna be lazy but
stand up if you actually some of you are
not standing up I don't want this
laziness stand up if you were a human
being who now actually gets upset with
another person calls you I just want
everybody to look around we're looking
at about 30 percent sit down I
appreciate that it's good for blood
circulation to I say 35 percent of the
human beings in this room right now in
2014 actually are mad when somebody else
calls them just think about how much the
world has changed just in five years
when somebody called you that was
probably the height of a relationship
that you had right we are now in a place
the reason
these thirty five percent of the people
and let's clap it up for them because
they're pioneers I'm clapping for them
they're pioneers because when I come
back here in 36 months 80% of you gonna
stand up because what those 35% have
realized that the other 65% have not
tasted yet is technology is in a place
where somebody shouldn't be bothering
you on your time how many people here
have texted somebody else and said hey
is now a good time to call raise your
hand
you're considerate human beings the
other bunch in this room your [ __ ] faces
what's happened my friends is technology
is changing the world in a way that look
I looked very careful I did something
very interesting I had a little more
time than normal
unlike to this talk I looked at all the
hashtags and I looked at a lot of your
BIOS in the audience and this is a very
look if you're in this room if you're
here if you care to be at this
conference and pay attention to the
content that they laid out you were so
much more ahead of the world then you
probably realized it's hard for you to
actually take yourself out of the bubble
you live in professionally all their
contemporaries of thinking about the
same things but the truth is as a whole
your glue matically ahead of the market
but even this room including me who
fancies himself and knowing where shits
going every one of us in this room is
grossly heavily under estimating what's
actually happening here the internet
which is about 20 years old the consumer
Internet and I know there's some nerd in
the background saying hey actually in
1957 I know nerd
but I mean when normal people went on
the Internet
we're talking about 20 years guys how
many people in this room remember the
world pre-internet you remember the
world free internet staggering number
it's crazy to think about the world free
internet actually um I'm going for
traumatic loss we are living through the
single biggest culture shift in human
history
with all due respect to the printing
press and other things that have come
along this thing that we got all lucky
to be a part of that much long when our
grandkids are long gone when people look
back at this era we got lucky now you
know how it is right like that Chinese
program interesting times good and bad
and that's the truth we're living
through the Second Industrial Revolution
we are seeing wealth being created that
we've never seen before because the
shifts are so great right we're living
through a time where everything's
changing so quickly that people are
either scared or completely thrilled
depending on your DNA but no matter
where you sit on this and no matter how
you think about this what this is all
letting out to is a very simple game
which is what do you do for a living and
do you provide value and most of all do
you whether you call it storytelling
whether you call it marketing whatever
you want to call it the biggest thing
that I'm here to talk about today is one
simple thing I've now spent 20 years of
my life being professional before that
you heard the lemonade stands what for a
lot of you don't know here is when I was
13 I was selling baseball cards in the
malls of New York and New Jersey making
three four thousand dollars a weekend
you're right it was DNA you know it was
just always there and now that I've done
this and I've done it successfully I
kind of look at the world and now that I
feel like I'm getting into an
interesting part you know I've always
been the whiz kid in the wine world and
things that major now is I've become in
a different chapter of my life going to
a different place where you know funny
things are said to me like what people
roll up on me to take a selfie with me
and they're like I watched your Wine
Show when I was in you
hi I'm like [ __ ] you know like okay
getting a little older there's something
that I want to share with you guys so
the variable difference to why I built
the fastest-growing liquor store in
America the reason why I invested in
Facebook and Twitter and Tumblr and uber
and Birchbox and made a lot of money but
more importantly got access to watch how
they navigated their first five years
for the last four years and especially
in the last 24 months I've grown
vaynermedia which is a social media
strategy and creative shop I started
with my brother we've grown it from 20
to 400 employees in the last 30 months
and that company works with fortune 500
clients like General Electric PepsiCo
dove Unilever big big brands so whether
it's a big fortune 500 company that I
spent a lot of time now with whether
it's a startup that's gone from zero to
billions whether it's the small business
that I grew up in whether it's the small
businesses that I consult for have
friends or jam with people I tried to
really take them all together and say
what's the one thing that makes Facebook
work but Plurk and all the other things
that could have been Facebook not work
right what's the one thing that makes
Unilever PepsiCo do well or not well
because there's only so much I can
control in that world what's the
difference what's the one theme that I
can share with a room like this no
matter what the [ __ ] you do in this room
whether you're b2b or b2c or you're a
startup or you're sole entrepreneur
music radio you saw t-shirts the one
thing that I'm completely convinced is
the variable for success within this
room across the board from here to there
to there to here the one thing that is a
common thread in my 20 year career that
I'm now completely obsessed with I start
a twenty five million dollar fund in
January I'm investing based on this
thesis the one thing that I want every
person to walk out of here with is do
you do you market in the year that we
actually live in that is the reason
people are winning and
is the reason people are losing the
reason companies are going out of
business is because they're not
marketing and executing in 2014 there's
a lot of people in this room so part of
the fact that I wanted to context the
room and looked at all your Twitter
handles up there and looked at your bro
profiles I also then looked at your
business's social presence to get a
sense of what's actually happening here
and so the question becomes very very
simple the truth is and I think a lot of
you know this whether you work for an
organization or you do it for yourself
and if you do it for yourself you know
it might be money might be time it might
be a lot of variables to why you aren't
executing to the best of your ability to
the knowledge you have of how to store
retail or work the market that we
actually live in but here's what's
happening my friends 99 percent of
businesses from beginning to end from
fortune one down to guy and gal start
their business yesterday that whole
variable 99% of businesses are not
marketing in the year that we actually
live in there's a lot of people in this
room when I looked at the Facebook pages
and the web pages tons of your web pages
in this room are not even mobile
optimized they're not even responsive in
a world where more than half the people
now consume content in a mobile world
yet you're here so you know so there's
factors that are stopping you it's
either money or its time or it's lack of
education or it's laziness or it's the
scariest one of all romance I'll get
into that in a minute but whatever it is
and by the way the funniest part is me
too me too we all do it the big variable
is this I sit in rooms with companies
that are spending twenty to fifty
million dollars in marketing in a year
and they're wasting it they're wasting
it because the romantic they're wasting
it because they're used to doing it one
way how many people in this room now
watch television and here's another
theme on your time meaning how many
people in this room do not watch outside
of sports when you're watching your
program TV you're watching it on your
time meaning you're watching it on
whatever you guys have here what do you
guys call it DVR what's that great
you're watching the show when you want
to watch it not when it actually airs
raise your hands
oh good everybody
how many of you are fast-forwarding
every single commercial when given the
option everybody
meanwhile my clients are spending tens
of billions of dollars to tell you a
story in a place where 2014 technology
has taken you away from being able to
actually see it I landed in Manchester's
Airport I drove an hour and 15 to be
here seven years ago if I was giving
this talk since I was awake and I can't
really sleep in a car I would have
looked out the window and seen the
beautiful countryside and all the things
I would have seen you know what else I
would have seen a fuckload of billboards
right seven years ago
in 2007 I would have seen a bunch of
billboards in 2014 you know what I did I
looked at my goddamn phone through the
entire hour and 15 minutes until I got
to the hotel I actually have no idea
what the world looks like between
Manchester and this [ __ ] place none
so what does that mean it means I
actually not against print or radio or
television or outdoor billboards not
against them I still think that people
maybe my phone ran out of battery and I
would have looked outside right I hope I
still think that things happen I still
think that some of these things do
penetrate you but there can't be a
single person in this room who thinks
the value of traditional media is worth
the same money today than it was 10
years ago because the one thing that
we're paying for the one thing all of
you were paying for the other thing
we're connected by is we're battling for
attention before you tell me how great
your app is or b2b service or your book
or your sneaker before you tell me how
great this [ __ ] product is you've got
to get my attention to tell me that and
right now getting attention has gotten
really really hard right and more
importantly we don't have time or
patience or acceptance anymore for when
somebody stops us from doing what we
want to do to interrupt us and tell them
about our shoe we grew up in a world for
the last 75 years where you know if you
wanted to watch a television show it
went to a commercial
you said look 30 years ago there weren't
remote controls in a lot of homes 40
years ago right you sat there watching
your favorite show in the 70s 80s and I
went to commercial you consumed that
commercial right so banner ads how many
people here have done banner ad
marketing in their career raise your
hand
great check this out in 1995 when I
started doing banner ads for
winelibrary.com I was getting a 20
percent click-through on banner ads to
zero not point two zero to zero point
zero click the ratio you know why
because marketers hadn't ruined banner
ads yet it's what we do
remember email marketing right how many
people here have done email marketing in
their career you ready for this [ __ ]
doozy 1996 400,000 people on my
winelibrary.com
email list 89% open rates yeah if you're
35 now you're a hero you're a hero
why because for some of the old-timers
here you guys remember like I do
in 1995 six seven eight nine we read
every word of every email that's what we
did now we delete everything cuz it's
all spam ninety percent of it right
marketers ruin everything and by the way
when I had a hundred thousand people
following me on Twitter versus the
million-plus I have now and I tweeted
something I got more engagement in 2008
and 9 than I do today because the
attention was there and the depth was
there my friends the single biggest
problem right now in marketing and
business is that everybody is so
obsessed with with with is what we value
how many impressions can I get how many
people on your list how many followers
do you have
with nobody is spending enough time on
depth I could I could if there was one
person in this audience right now I
would be giving you this same [ __ ]
talk because for me it's about depth
because for me depth is how you big
long-term real businesses depth is how
you win if with worked Zynga
and LivingSocial and Groupon would be
the biggest companies in the world
because they figured out how to buy
customers and build with the reason
those companies have struggled over the
last three to four years is they didn't
understand retention they understood
acquisition but they didn't understand
retention and so we're living in a time
right now that's very interesting
because you have to understand the
psychology of human beings bless you you
have to understand the psychology of
human beings in a world now where
numbers are public we get caught up in
that game in a world where we can show
our Twitter followers or our Facebook
followers do you know that the average
14-year old girl in America spends over
two hours on one Instagram photo that
she puts up because she puts it up first
of all she takes enormous anywhere
between 8 and 20 minutes to get the
lighting just right for her selfie right
but that's not where her time is spent
it's way more [ __ ] interesting and
way more scary depending on which way
you want to look at it where she spends
her time is when she posts it if that
picture does not get enough likes within
the first five to seven minutes her
self-esteem is wrapped up in that
engagement number and she takes it down
and retakes
another one we're living through a very
big culture shift one that we are
grossly under estimating one in a world
where we're not talking about 15 minutes
of fame anymore we're talking about
everybody has 15 people that think
they're famous and that dynamic is a
huge shift when we become creators not
just consumers it changes the paradigm
shift right
it also affects something very important
that thing I talked to you about earlier
attention when everybody's producing
content and the cost of entry to produce
content is zero it's just time because
the platforms like Instagram and
Facebook and snapchat have mass reach
none of us could have started a
TV network or a newspaper 25 30 40 years
ago we didn't have the money to build
all that infrastructure but the internet
with these apps that have all the users
on it has been built for us and all we
have to do is do the creative which oh
by the way every day that goes by
becomes less expensive because we as
human beings value authentic creative
over over produced thus the cost can be
zero and so my friends what I come here
to tell you is this I really don't care
what you sell for a living
I really don't and very honestly it
actually doesn't matter it doesn't
matter if your b2b it doesn't matter if
you're an artist it doesn't matter if
your student it doesn't matter if you're
trying to do this for a non-profit
you know nonprofits anybody here in the
NGO space nonprofit business great so
I'm fascinated by that space I would
tell you out of all the industries that
do social media the worst I would say
it's nonprofits it is unbelievable to me
in a world using my terminology if you
go map the top 200 nonprofits on social
networks right now 95% of them are
throwing right hooks on every single
post the amount of people in nonprofit
space that hit me up daily asking for
money or for me to tweet without even
saying hello to me is staggering because
they have the audacity that because
they're a non-profit they deserve to be
able to go in for the clothes not in a
negative way it's the structure and that
same DNA is something I want to talk to
all of you about just because you have a
business just because you have a service
entitles you to absolutely zero
customers and if you ask me when I see
the biggest flaw in all the startups and
the entry level people or the people
that are doing you know maybe they've
been in corporate but doing their own
thing for the first time there is a
stunning misnomer across the masses that
you're entitled to any customers when
you start your business you have to earn
every single one of them and the only
way this room
and this country and this world is going
to earn customers is by a very few core
principles number one are you proud of
what you're selling a lot of people tell
me they hate being a salesperson
I actually think salespeople the purest
ones are the best people in the world I
really do
when I sell my stuff it comes from such
a [ __ ] like great place I feel very
good about what I do you know great I
feel about myself right now standing in
front of you
I truly believe I'm giving very good
advice oh by the way and I'm also very
realistic I come here today to affect
one person the kind of marketing that
I'm looking to be done an execution I'm
looking be done is hard it takes a lot
of time and a lot of discipline and it
takes something that 99% of you in this
room do not have the one word I love the
most the one word if you look at my
frantic energy you'd never think I have
but is the foundation of my entire
success the thing it takes is patience
and that is something that is lacking
heavily in this fast-paced world which
is becoming a detriment to a lot of the
businesses in this room and so a lot of
people say they hate selling you know
why because I know as I sit here without
knowing any of you I know that forty
thirty twenty-five percent of you in
this room don't even believe in what
you're selling you do not believe in
your product it's just the way it is so
that's number one
you have to believe that what you're
selling is worth its money is your
product and service worth it and I'm not
talking about putting on blinders and
looking at it at itself the amount of
people that don't look at the
competitive landscape somebody came to
me the other day and like Gary my social
media agencies not doing well yours is
doing so great I've been a fan of yours
I talk about all the same stuff that did
that so I sit down with him I'm kind of
I get into that once awhile I get caught
and you know I have no time I just like
and then I get really pissed I'm like
who the [ __ ] is Don Thompson and then I
look and my assistant has the tweet
where I'm like yeah I'll give you 15
minutes I'm like [ __ ] you Gary anyway
so Don Thompson comes in I sit down with
him and I'm like he tells me all this
stuff and it feels very fluffy to be
very honest with you I mean I think one
of the other things that a lot of people
in this room should be thinking and
talking about I think we should be
talking more about which is the amount
of fake social media gurus and agencies
and people that are in the space right
now is completely out of control these
are people that sold real estate or
vitamins on the internet five minutes
ago so that's something that needs to be
talked about a little bit more so he's
one of these characters I don't begrudge
him but I'm listening to his pitch and
he's never sold anything in his life
right like he's not like a businessman
he just is opportunistic and he's smart
and trends he has this agency that's
fine so I don't think the quality but
then we'll completely blew me out of my
chair and I picked it up like wrestling
style and hit him with it was when he
told me how much he wants to charge
he was basically charging close to
Boehner we were putting 11 people on an
account charging $40,000 a month to a
brand this guy's putting himself in like
some intern and was asking for 30,000
and I was just like I just laughed in a
non negative I tried to make it as
non-negative as possible and I was like
bro did you even like context the market
do you understand that one-man shops
like you are three to four thousand
dollars a month kind of businesses and
so it's not just knowing if you feel
good about the price what what has been
baffling to me back to what I said
earlier which is the amount of fake
entrepreneurs it's all supply and demand
isn't it right like you have to know
what everything else is being sold for
if you want to know what you're selling
your thing for so look I'm a I'm very
passionate about building businesses and
telling stories in this chapter of my
life I'm using this gift that I was
given to sell stuff and make money and
like help my employees and help people
that are willing to listen to me I'm
excited for future chapters in my life
I've started those things whether it's
going to be - whether it's politics or
to save the world or whatever it is it's
all the same game right it's all the
same game do you tell your stories
contextually properly in the places
where people pay attention I stand
before you right now with no fear insane
with zero
Oh hedge with what I'm about to say
Facebook at this second back to
marketing in the year we live in
Facebook on July what is it 8th 2014 as
you record this right now
Facebook July 8 2014 is the single best
place to market to sell stuff on the
return on the dollar amount that you put
in in the world period yet here's the
problem at hand we now live in a world
and you guys know this we live in a
world where we have a bunch of headline
readers we read headlights by the way
I've come to realize I do this too and
other things I now no longer get into
any deep conversations around anything
besides social media wine the New York
Jets and root beer period I will have a
lightweight conversation with you about
health care Wars politics all these
other things but I've been listening to
other people who think they know about
social and they read a couple of Ad Age
articles and a couple Guardian articles
and say Facebook's bad now organic
reaches down it's Facebook even worth it
anymore and I sit there and I'm
completely baffled because let me tell
you what's going on here now this is a
new part of how I want to talk I've been
speaking for 5 6 7 years usually it gets
people riled up they're pumped it's good
they're entertained now I'm trying to
figure out how to add at least one very
deep tangible call-to-action that
everybody can leave with and now here's
where I'm going with this part my
friends if you do not know what a
Facebook dark post unpublished post is
you need to google it and you need to
watch the videos on Facebook or YouTube
to learn Facebook right now perfect
execution is no longer putting out
content to your community it is to go in
the back end of Facebook and to use page
editor and to create a segment a cohort
a audience that you pick from everybody
in this room right now for very little
money in the scheme of things compared
to Google or anything else that you can
do buying ads on the exchange or
anything else you can do with no minimum
every person in this room can go to
Facebook right now and mark it to every
single person that is on Facebook you
can reach them in their newsfeed
natively not on the right side of the
website but in their feed with a piece
of content that you reverse engineer
from the cohort the audience
segmentation that you create let me
explain an employee on my paid team who
knows that I'm an investor in Birchbox
and barkbox anybody familiar with
Birchbox and barkbox just curious
okay very good small amount Birchbox is
a makeup of the Month Club right you
basically get for 20 bucks or ten bucks
you get a box each month with seven or
eight different samples of makeup it was
a business that exploded in the u.s.
they've done extremely well barkbox is
the same thing you pick the size of your
dog small medium large and each month
for 20 or 30 bucks different toys and
treats come this way you get to explore
new things for your pet not really neat
both businesses are doing extremely well
they did extremely well because they
[ __ ] marketed in the year we lived in
and they did target segmentation so they
went to Facebook and they ran ads
against people who owned who owned
boxers who owned mousers who owned
golden retrievers they put a [ __ ]
golden retriever in the picture and they
said Firefox and guess what happened it
worked because the only people that saw
it were people that had golden
retrievers understand so one of my kids
young kid on the paid team learning this
very simply started he's really into
golf
he's a scratch golfer good for him
anyway he started something called bogey
box it's a golf of the mom month box all
he did was target the right people the
amount of data that you can target on
Facebook including MasterCard data
imagine targeting somebody who spends
real money on golf equipment not likes a
page not theoretically goes to espn.com
so he must love bourbon not that [ __ ] a
human being who spent money on golf
equipment he is the one that saw the ad
and for 1,100 bucks
he ran ads and he sold forty thousand
dollars worth of bogey boxes
the site didn't exist the basic business
didn't even exist and that is what I'm
talking about
how many people in this room are and by
the way if you raise your hand I'm
probably gonna jump out of the audience
ask you the name of the business and if
you're lying I'm gonna tweet out and
blogpost about how you're [ __ ] liar
so before I ask this question I warn you
because I'm a weird character how many
people in this room are actively I would
say have run 20 or more Facebook dark
posts for their business raise your hand
one so this is the world we live in we
are at a marketing conference where
people are into this space
right that if you're here you know what
a [ __ ] hashtag is right if you're
here you're paying attention you've
heard of me you've heard of the other
speakers you wanted to be here to be
educated you're running your business in
2014 yet these single number one best
tactic to sell stuff and convert and do
business on the Internet
right the second is on Facebook dark
posts and one good-looking dude with a
great beard is the only person in this
room that is executing and that my
friends is the single thing that I think
about every single day which is you can
throw as much hyperbole around around
let's care about our audience and the
Thank You economy and Jab Jab Jab
[ __ ] right hook and all this stuff
and the bottom line is if you are not an
executor and a practitioner you will
lose you can talk to me about anything
you want you want to know what the ROI
of a basketball is for me
dick zero for LeBron a billion dollars
please if you came here with any
audacity left of is there any ROI in
social media there's ROI in anything
that people pay attention to but if you
don't know how to use it you lose